hồi chế miếng về đội mới không chỉ là dí sản tin thần mà còn làm cội nền tảng vự chắc cho con cuộc đội mới toàn sản đất nước,
giòn đảng tà khởi sướng và lãnh đảo từ năm 1990 đã mì sau đến nay.
Chủ trị khổ chế miếng chính là người nhoa dưỡng và chuyên cầm hướng về khắc bỏ phát triển đất nước Việt Nam, phong vi hải mục.
Qua cần muốn miếng năm 1990, đất nước đã đạt được những thành tư có ý nghĩa lịch sử.
Chính chỉ xáu hồi ôn đình cúc phong anh linh được tăng cường, măn má xáu hồi có bước phát triển tích gợp.
Nên xân chủ xáu hồi chủng nghĩa ngày càng được phát vi và mở giọt,
góc hình cùng bố và tăng cường khối đại đoàn kết xân tỏng.
Sức mạnh của đất nước được năng lên, nóc lập chủ quyền của đất nước được dữ bự.
Quán hệ đối ngoại giọc mở và đăng li và chủ sốc.
Vị thế và quy tín của Việt Nam cho chủ quyết tế ngày một nâng càng.
Đó là tiên đe quan trọng để lất nước tiếp tục,
đại mạnh công cuộc đổi mới toàn diện gần đồng bộ.
Phát triển sáng tạo sớm từ nước ta trở thành nước công việc thử giải đại.
Chào tế chính ảy, của các bạn tinh gọi bộ máy chống quan liều tham dụng lạng bi bốn là điều
chủ tịch của chi Minh tương nhiều lần cạnh báo và dính mạnh.
Đăng trở thành địa nhấn, cải cách có ý nghĩa chính lợn với sự ảnh đạo của đàn mạnh đồng đầu là đồng chi tạo bi thu tôn lần.
Thông cuộc đổi mới tinh gọi bộ máy của hệ thử chiến trị, quan diện hơn báo giữa hệ.
Chúng tôi không chỉ mấy đá tý xa, nhưng tư tưởng rồi mới sáng tạo của người vẫn đàn xôi sáng từng bước tiến vẫn chắc của rất tạo kiện năm.
Chên hạnh trình xây dật đất nước, phong vi hạnh phúc.